donc la présentation ce sera je pense
après je pense que c'est comme ça cet
après-midi-là au restaurant le prieur de
l'abbaye des vaux de cernay chef
cuisinier et chef sommelier travail sur
les accords mets et vins de la nouvelle
carte vous avez un oui j'avais 14 ans
qu'on se connaît et on s'entend très
bien
14 ans d'une collaboration quotidienne
pour des repas haut de gamme
constamment en évolution tous les plats
sont dégustés avec toute l'équipe de
salle et la cuisine et je dirais même au
cours du premier service ont refait
encore auront on apporte quelques
ajustements alain pontoise au s'occupe
des caves du prieur depuis 29 ans les
600 références ils sont classés de
manière bien précise
c'est un plaisir c'est que quand on
rentre on sait que les bouteilles sont
bien rangés et tout se tient d'abord on
sale dans une maison parisienne il y
rencontre un membre de l'association des
sommeliers de la capitale ici dès son
amour pour l'art des cépages une passion
qui ne le quitte plus et dont il fait
son métier
c'est paisible et de temps en temps ça
fait du bien elle dépasser 15 minutes
avec en plus en regardant les étiquettes
cela notre havre de paix à la table du
prieur et développe sa carte la
sommellerie est un savoir ancien mais
alain pontoise hausse et prendre en
compte ces évolutions le vin et de
vivant on peut pas dire je fais une
carte je garde les vignerons pendant 30
ans j'ai gardé les mêmes millions vignon
je gage d'échangés millésime
je pense que là
je pense que je fais pas mon métier le
sommelier géré sa cave
mais il travaille également en salle 18
tables a conseillé à chaque service pour
vomir et où les verts avant de partir
cet après midi s'il vous plaît faut
aimer les gens parce que c'est vrai que
ce volet dans une maison les personnes
ne pose beaucoup de questions on rentre
on a la chance d'avoir des contacts avec
du client et puis et puis avec le
migneron combat dans le vignoble c'est
vrai qu'on a des moments des changes
quand même qu'ils sont qui sont
importants voilà donc je trouvais ça
intéressant régulièrement alain pontoise
on rend visite à son ancien apprenti
enzo oc a commencé en salle avant
d'embrasser la même passion que son
tuteur
aujourd'hui il est assistant sommelier à
la table du 11 à versailles c'est plus
mon c'est plus mon apprenti maintenant
c'est celle d'un homme qui est plus et
dégustation où il fait ses voyages il
est avec un nouveau chef sommelier donc
il découvre d'autres choses que moi j'ai
pas pensé ou j'ai pas découvert où j'ai
pas déguster un mentorat qui prend
aujourd'hui une forme d'amitié
l'ancien apprenti est fier de montrer
son nouveau terrain dur on a fait
rentrer donc de nouveau moteur peut vous
pouvez donc sur le monde la vallée je
vous dirai ça fait vraiment sympa donc
c'est un vigneron qu'à un hectare de
vignes pour gagner les personnes qui
nous ont transmis certaines choses qui
nous ont
qu'ils nous ont éduqués qui nous ont
appris je pense que dans dix ans car bon
c'est pas impossible que j'appelle un si
j'ai un souci sur un accord une
transmission au coeur du métier du
sommelier alain pontoise au a fait de
l'univers du vin sa deuxième famille
avec laquelle il entend bien continuer
de nombreuses années prochain challenge
potentiel le concours de meilleur
ouvrier de france